how do you know if a business idea is
worth pursuing so my take on that is is
think about what you are going to
uniquely bring to the table sometimes
I've been at a restaurant with a friend
and they're like oh this restaurant is
doing so well I think I could do this
and and they start thinking about maybe
I'll open up another restaurant just
like that across the street well I think
my friends in that situation are
probably under estimating how much work
that the restaurant were in had put into
it how much thought they put into it and
also if you open up a identical
restaurant across the street well that's
just going to hurt both of your
businesses and neither of you might have
a viable business another thing is you
could look at a business that someone
else started and you might see the cash
register running and there's a lot of
customers but you don't realize
everything all of the costs all of the
risks that that person took on their
rent might be a lot you might just be
going during the busy time and if you go
to the next day during lunch there might
not be anyone there and so it's very
easy to always see think that the grass
is greener on the other side most
entrepreneurs will tell you that even
the most successful successful ventures
went through their dark periods and went
through a period where it looked like it
was going to fail it didn't look like it
was going to work out and so what I
would say if you have a business idea is
a one thing about what you're going to
uniquely bring to the table maybe it is
an idea that no one's ever thought about
before but maybe it it is an idea that
people have thought about before but you
have a unique way of approaching it or
you have unique skills or a unique team
that can approach it right or you kind
of see the Nexus of of several of these
things and I would try to test the idea
as well as possible you know is can you
can you put out some advertising for
your business before it even exists and
and see if people respond can you build
a prototype of a product and see if
people want it and the more that you can
test it in that way and say wow there's
actually a product market fit here or a
service market fit here people really
want what this idea is then then I think
you might be onto something obviously
the ideal is you even start the business
on a small scale without necessarily
going all in yet
and seeing that wow there's a lot of lot
of demand for this so once again oh no
right answer here always when you're
starting a business you really just have
to prepare yourself mentally that there
will be rough patches but if you can
come up with something and have a unique
take on it and test it and it's actually
getting traction with folks and and
you're able to get the capital and you
yourself have the capital you've saved
up maybe if things get a little bit
rough as you start your business I think
you might be in a good position to start
it